Lurch got left in a Lurch China
rejecting pressure from climates are
John Kerry to do more to address global
warming Kerry personally traveled to
Beijing with the hopes that the Chinese
will cut carbon emissions but those
efforts crashing harder than Kerry's
windsurfing career
we had very Frank conversations but we
came here to break new ground
which we think is important at this
stage
and it is clear
that we are going to need a little more
work to be able to complete that task
you know it's interesting Daniel I look
at him it's like he really wants to be
in the Hall of Presidents he acts like
it right but he'll never get there but
he acts like a hot like a robotic kind
of uh Statesman how much CO2 did this
noxious blowhard put into the air with
his tree he flew seven thousand miles to
get there you could have had the same
results with a zoom meeting yes Daniel
Turner mentioned on Twitter as I saw uh
he was Becky he's basically begging
China to reduce emissions he got nowhere
and president XI has said
we we will get the new before we want to
get to the new but we don't want to
discard the old before we get there yes
this is just logical and it makes sense
and in the meantime America's job
creators they have reduced emissions so
much here through Innovation but also
they're not rewarded for their
Innovation they are beaten over the head
with more regulations which prevents us
from getting to the new in a faster way
see that problem the circular logic
there you go Jessica like John Kerry
you're tall
is that does that is that why he's so
arrogant
explain I mean tall people have a lot of
advantages in life if you want Jesse and
I to talk about that for the rest of
this yes that is something we would
agree on we got something today
um
really see this as a tremendous
embarrassment necessarily odds are the
Chinese are not going to say you know
what you're right we're responsible for
a third of the global emissions we'll
sign on to whatever you have to say I
was just glad that he didn't get kicked
out on day one because the Chinese since
we've kind of been a little strange
about Taiwan and we had the you know
we're going to go in we're not going to
win et cetera the last year has been
pretty Frosty
um so I think having at least a
conversation is a good thing but yes if
this is your job to fix the climate it's
obviously not great if one of the
biggest superpowers and emitters doesn't
want to do anything with you so Jessica
says judge that it's obvious he failed
uh it was embarrassing humiliating for
America and we have to keep paying for
these conversations oh let's go here and
have a conversation nothing happens but
you and I pay for it Jessica I pay a lot
of taxes you do you do but you love it
yeah that's why you want people to stay
in New York so more people can pay taxes
look you know what I did it I
I'd spin off of what uh what Dana did
okay so uh he takes a plane to China uh
he gets nothing done so he flies home so
he flew for about 40 hours the jet
emissions were 25 metric tons okay uh
it's the same as 64 000 miles which is
30 round trips back and forth from New
York to Las Vegas 30 times and this guy
says and cares about climate change I
mean really and the truth is I mean we
keep telling them we want these electric
uh uh vehicles and lithium batteries and
they're developing a coal plant every
day to satisfy the needs that we have
and then we go over there like we're
talking out of two sides of our mouth
saying oh but to give us some clean
emissions reduce your admissions but you
know give us more batteries and if you
build a cold plant every three days it's
okay yeah you know Jesse I think he
makes these virtue trips to offset his
vices you know he spends a lot of money
or on copious material can consumption
Yachts going around having fun and this
is his way of giving back plazars
organizarre this is what they do today
gallivant and they traips around in
someone else's time and then they
negotiate and they wear silk ties Sean
Carey's whole career I'm not surprised
the Chinese told them to stuff it why
would they what are they going to make
less money because Carrie said so what
are they going to stop growing so fast
because Carrie said knock it off come on
countries don't do things that slow them
down or that make them less money it's
just human nature Carrie should know
that because he's this close to being
human nicely done
coming up it turns out that I'm 100
right on everything
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now